i mentioned earlier in the program that
last year amari cooper told me he wanted
to have 2
000 for himself sounds like he's not
going to hog
2 000 this year not that he got there
last year he wants a thousand
for all three amari cooper michael
gallup and cd lamb
we were trying to figure out yesterday
when we drafted
the best number two receivers in the nfl
i mean one of the challenges who are the
number two receivers
who is the number two receiver behind
amari cooper is it gallup or is it cd
lambsharin
are we sure it's not amari cooper i i'm
just saying mike
they paid him a hundred million dollars
and and you do wonder
when they paid him that hundred million
dollars if they knew what they know now
that cd lamb would be sitting there when
they drafted and they could draft him
would they have paid amari cooper what
they paid him i'm thinking no
now i know that what they the price they
gave up to get him
but look amari cooper was terrible last
year at
on the road and we saw him get benched
we saw him standing on the sideline
there late in the season on the road
because he wasn't doing
uh what he was supposed to be doing and
running routes and everything else
i think michael gallup i'm not saying
he's their number one receiver i agree
with you that amari cooper is a number
one receiver i'm saying amari cooper
needs to be
to do more to live up to that 100
million dollar
contract uh but i think it's michael
gallup and i like this guy and i think
he's really good and i think he does all
the right things and he had
1100 yards just over 1100 yards last
season and i think he's
he could be their go-to receiver he
could be their number one receiver now
the problem comes
two years from now another season after
this and and you're looking at
how are you going to pay him and you're
not going to pay him so he's going to
walk away and get a huge contract
somewhere else because you've got cd
lamb
and amari cooper but i think michael
gallup is really good i think he can be
a number one receiver
and i think there's a chance he could be
a number one receiver on this team in
the next two years
you mentioned the amari cooper contract
and they had to pay cooper after what
they gave up to get him
during the 2018 season they knew what
they were getting themselves into by way
of the option year contract and then the
possibility of the franchise tag
but here's the thing to remember because
yeah it's 100 million dollars
technically it's a two-year commitment
at about 40 million
after these next two seasons shireen
they could just decide
we have our guy in cd land we don't need
amari cooper anymore whether they trade
him whether they cut him
whether they squeeze him to take less
money so maybe
it's cd lam and michael gallup over the
long haul maybe the things that we
noticed last year the performance on the
road the benching
maybe this ultimately leads to the
cowboys just keeping him long enough to
justify the first round pick they gave
up to get
him and then focusing on lamb and gallop
and whoever else they may be able to
find
you know amari does great things and i
love his personality he's quiet in a
locker room and
and you know he's a good leader he's a
good teammate he does all the right
things
but i think he needs to do more on the
field and contribute more than what he
has and to me he hasn't shown he's the
number one receiver he hasn't
made the great catches he hasn't put up
the really huge yards he hasn't been the
go-to guy
for dak prescott all the time and
sometimes when he has tried to go to him
either omaree hasn't made the player
it's turned into a turnover so
he needs to step up and do more this
season or they could be looking at that
possibility after two seasons of moving
on from him
hey shereen here's the key too remember
in the final
year or two of dez bryant when dak
prescott was just getting right
there was that question as to whether or
not dak prescott trusted dez bryant
would throw him the ball
you know dez bryant's like hey i'll go
get that ball i don't care if it doesn't
look like i'm open and that created
friction
is there a level of trust that there
needs to be between dak prescott and
murray cooper
yeah well and and i think that is a big
question and i don't think it's there
yet
and i think that's still yet to be shown
that that he
is going to trust him in crunch time you
know when they need a first down when
they need a touchdown when they need
something to happen in the red zone
whatever it may be
i think that's yet to be proven and and
when you when you see amari cooper over
there standing on the sidelines
and the cowboys are trying to come back
in a game and amari's standing on the
sidelines i i just i think it's not
there
quite yet i think he needs to do more to
to show that and dak needs to have more
trust in him
uh to make those plays when it matters
whatever it is
it needs a change for the cowboys if
he's going to be their number one
receiver and and
and really uh take the pressure and let
michael gallup and cd lamb do some
things
uh for you and take some of those double
teams i'm not sure how much they
they double team amari cooper all the
time either
because they're not concerned about him
all the time so he needs to do a little
bit more on the field i think for the
cowboys this season
and his deal is a fairly simple
proposition he gets 20 million this year
20 million next year 20 million the next
year it's five years 20 million each
year
after that second season it becomes very
easy to move on the guarantees go away
the cap hit would not be that bad
and michael gallup's under contract two
more years at very very low amounts
that's when you can have that transition
from amari cooper over to michael gallup
along with c.d lam who would still be
under his rookie contract
for several more years and this is a
relevant conversation because
dak prescott's going to continue to be
not cheap 31.4 this year 37.68 next year
at some point do they sound into a
long-term deal if they do he's going to
eat up a lot of cap space
you can't have a ton of cap space tied
up in your receivers
especially if lam ends up being really
good
and commands a big contract i i just i
feel like even though amari cooper
got one of the great receiver contracts
in free agency without actually
becoming uh you know a free agent who
left for another team
it may not be a long stay for him
especially as these other guys step up
so if it's three guys for a thousand
yard shireen it may not last for very
long
because the other two may be the ones
who are there uh and uh
it's just you know that's the way the
business goes um
all right mike take a break mike i have
to tell you though you know my favorite
cowboys number two receiver of all time
right tony hill
is my favorite cowboys receiver and you
know who he was
not number one to and that would be drew
pearson
wait a minute just gave me a chance
that's a long way to just
stick it in my back and twist thanks
matt is tony hill
is is tony that's what you guys i knew
you were talking about me during break
you know when you get that feeling
they're talking about me i know there's
i know they're planning something
they're plotting against me
was tony hill the guy who caught the
pass in the super bowl and immediately
put it on the ground was that him
you know what i'm talking about it was a
golden reaction that was tony hill
uh no it was okay no i think that was
tony hill
that that was not a catch all due
respect to the cowboys who beat
agreed they still would have beat they
still would have beaten the broncos that
day because the broncos
offense was worse than abysmal but
that highlight and maybe we can find it
during the break he catches the ball
and hits the ground and kind of does and
the balls that he leaves the ball behind
it's like he never really has the ball
or any feet on the ground or anything
it's just like he has it
he tumbles and leaves the ball behind uh
it may have been tony hill it may have
been golden richards we'll confirm that
during the break
i say that i say that all the time and
then we forget but this time we'll
remember
when we return though we will have a
draft of the
things that we miss about
not having training camp in the
preseason the way it usually is we'll be
back with more pfc live
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports